dark souls 3 is a perfect game due to
the way a book ends the entire series
but the only reason that i can say that
is because of how much this game is
being held up by its predecessors dark
souls 3 on its own is still a good game
but without all the effort put into the
story from dark souls 1 and 2 its
narrative wouldn't be as impactful
that's the beauty of the dark souls
trilogy it's one of the few series out
there that truly feels like a tightly
knit game many games get sequels but not
many truly feel like a proper sequel
just a game set in the same universe a
year or so after the previous game it
might make callbacks to the pass game
but not enough to feel like what
occurred in that game was important the
dark souls trilogy and its repetitive
ideas make the games feel properly
connected the age of fire the undead
curse hollowing and so much more have
been a prominent part of the series
since its inception which is why judging
these games individually based on their
stories is so difficult as each of these
games relies on each other to actually
make their story have an impact dark
souls 2 and 3 could not exist without
dark souls 1 and not just because of its
world-building and important characters
but because it's the game that showed us
what the age of fire is and why it's
important we then took this information
into dark souls 2 which showed us how
the age of fire is not all it's cooped
up to be and how as all the years go by
people are starting to embrace the fire
less and less this all comes to an end
to dark souls 3 a game that is purely
focused on the age of dark and why the
first flame needs to go each one of
these games provides a crucial step in
our journey and without even one of them
every other game loses its meaning we
already talked about the previous two
games and what they attempt to show to
the player and all these themes ideas
and plots all converge towards dark
souls 3 creating one of the best endings
in a series i've ever seen
and today i will explain why so without
wasting any more time
let's get started so ironically for a
game that's going to be about the age of
darkness and how much death and decay
the current age has caused it starts off
with an incredibly intense soundtrack
it's not even been 10 seconds and this
electrified feeling of exhilaration
seeps into your body dark souls is back
and it's time to kick some ass this
feeling continues right into the intro
cinematic and dark souls 3 weighs 0 time
getting into the story this is the first
time in the trilogy where the game
outright tells you who the main bosses
are which are the abyss watchers aldrich
saint of the deep and yorm the giant
there is also a fourth that isn't
mentioned but we'll discuss them a bit
later just like before it's four beings
who will need to be dealt with in order
to succeed but instead of them being the
four lord soul users or the four great
ones it's the four lords of cinder the
question is why are they so important
well oddly enough the game tells you but
the pure spectacle of the intro is so
hypnotizing you might not even realize
what was just said according to the
opening narration the bells only toll
when threatened the reason they're being
threatened is because the fire is fading
again but furthermore it's because
someone doesn't want to link the flame
that person being prince lothric since
the prince doesn't want to link the
flame the bells of awakening revived
previous lords of cinder from past
kingdoms each of these aforementioned
beings i mentioned earlier were people
who link the flame in their lifetimes
the bells assume that if they have
linked it already then they'll do it
again but they all refused the abyss
watchers aldrich and yorm don't want to
in the last ditch ever to make sure the
fire is linked the bells of awakening
have awoken other beings who are
unkindled people who have failed to link
the fire in the past but are now given a
second chance and we are one such person
known as the ashen one our job is to
defeat the lords of cinder and take
their ashes to their thrones as if they
won't come back willingly then their
ashes will serve as a substitute this is
the plot of the game no small objective
in between like finding vendrick or
ringing the bells right away from the
get-go we're tasked with killing these
beings and licking the flame assuming
you've played the previous games already
then you've heard this story twice
before and already know what you're
getting into which is why our first boss
isn't even 5 minutes into the game in
dark souls 1 it took around the same
time to fight the asylum demon but the
game also taught us about our inventory
and weaponry but also showed us that we
can converse with npcs and used an estus
flask dark souls 2 took a bit longer
with this as the first boss wasn't for a
couple hours and the basic tutorial can
take a bit of time to run through in
dark souls 3 we start with the estus
flask get get all our gear and start our
journey immediately there is no hand
holding here as the game assumes you've
done this all before and don't need much
of a refresher the reason why they put
udix in here is because he's supposed to
test our strength not just the ashen
one's strength but ours since dark souls
3 underwent some drastic changes in
regards to its combat and for those who
have noticed yes i'm using an axe again
it wasn't until starting this game that
i realized i'd used an axe for all three
of them so i figured it'd be quite
comical if i beat the entire trilogy
with the same weapon before killing
eudyx though we'll see him become
engulfed in this black form this is
called the pus of man this is a unique
disease that is taking over the kingdom
and it originates from the abyss similar
to how manus humanity went wild causing
him to become the ferocious beast that
we know in game it's possible that this
is happening to other hollows but on a
much grander scale as this won't be the
last time we see this pus of man in the
game after utyx we can take the coiled
sword from his body and use it to create
the bonfire at the new firelink shrine i
absolutely love the design of firelink
shrine from the moment you walk in and
see all the thrones lined up around the
bonfire you feel a sense of comfort it's
definitely my favorite across the entire
series but i loathe its location
firelink shrine feels so disconnected
from the rest of the world even though
majula was on the outskirts of draying
lake castle it at least became a nexus
for all the various paths that the
player could traverse to the cherry on
top years that we can't even travel to
the first location were forced to
teleport to it it just further shuts
this place away from the rest of the
kingdom there's no incentive to explore
the other areas of the level as we've
already seen everything it has i never
understood why the series slowly moved
towards this idea but it seemed to be a
massive hit amongst the team as this
would be used in other games going
forward from a pure gameplay perspective
the firelink shrine of dark souls 3 also
reverts to the changes in dark souls 2
to keep things more simplistic andre is
back and will handle anything regarding
our weapons from upgrades to infusions
and the shrine handmaid becomes our
all-encompassing merchant so no more
clutter like in dark souls 2. we also
have our new level up lady who is just
the fire keeper she doesn't have any
unique backstory like the emerald herald
but her condition does spark a few
questions it seems that all the fire
keepers have some sort of condition that
afflicts them anastasia the lady under
firelink shrine will initially be mute
and cannot be spoken to the darkmoonitus
in anor londo has a disfigured
appearance which is why she hides it
from us with her armor and this fire
keeper is blind this has always been
fascinating to me as i've never been
able to fully understand why this is the
case it's possible that this is a sort
of rite of passage and the fire keepers
are showing their willingness to the
flame by giving up something but what
they lose seems to differ across the
games it's possible that this is just a
coincidence but there's also an npc in
the game will meet called irina who
tries to be a fire keeper and is also
blind fire keepers being blind only
occurs in dark souls 3. so i've always
wondered why blindness is occurring now
instead of across the series it's
something we never get an answer to but
definitely a fascinating topic to
discuss speaking of the characters in
firelink shrine i want to talk about the
npcs though before we embark on our
journey third time's the charm as they
say since the npcs this game are handled
way better than in the previous two
titles my issue with each game is that
dark souls 1 kept replaying the same
fate of hollowing across all of its
characters which started losing its
value very quickly and dark souls 2
seemed to just make characters for the
rewards rather than their stories but
dark souls 3 seems to fix this issue the
quantity of the npcs has been
drastically reduced as they're only
around 27 or so in the main game there's
also very little overlap in the
merchants as each school of magic has
one designated npc with the exception of
pyromancy and while greyrat does have a
pretty useless inventory for the most
part since he's a thief you can actually
send him to find gear which will
increase his options this was so much
better as i didn't have to run around
the base finding the one merchant who
sells the item i need furthermore the
actual quests of the npcs were much more
enjoyable this time around there was
five standout characters for dark souls
3. but one interesting change with this
game though is that the npcs connect
with the main content both sigward and
henry have a connection with a specific
lord of cinder and yuri's questline ends
up becoming one of the endings of the
game i really liked this idea as so far
the npcs have been separate from the
main bosses so it was nice to see it all
intertwine with one another it'll be a
lot easier to explain what their quest
lines are alongside the main content so
we'll hold off on this for now which
means the only other two that we have to
talk about that have a more traditional
quest line are irina and cirrus as we
talked about before irina is blind and
this is because she came from her land
of kareem to become a fire keeper you
might recognize the name kareem as
oswald the trek and the marvelous
chester from dark souls 1 are all from
karim the reason we find irina here in
this cell is because she's filled and
hasn't become a fire keeper yet due to
this failure she believed that she was
unfit to tend the flames and fell into a
deep depression the night guarding her
is aegon of kareem and has a sworn duty
to protect her no matter her state of
being to progress her questline we need
to buy her spells if we buy her miracles
then we'll be able to give her the
enlightenment she needed and will
eventually become a fire keeper at
firelink shrine gameplay-wise she's
pretty useless in this state is not only
is there already a fire keeper but she's
also hundreds of feet away from the
player as opposed to the actual fire
keeper who is right next to you if we
however only buy her dark miracles we
further progress the ferocity of the
humanity with inside of her causing her
to be consumed by its dark power this
turns aegon hostile who will fight you
for betraying her she will eventually
start to become worried and asks us to
touch her against that she can tell who
is nearby but eventually she will not
recognize our touch and ask to be killed
it's a genuinely sad outcome and this
emotion has heightened further because
we're the ones that caused it hedoe
instead just kept purchasing her regular
miracles we could have saved her from
her impending fate it's a quest line of
two extremes one where she gets
everything she wants and one where she
loses everything and it all depends on
you as for siri she starts out as some
random person who appears at firelink
shrine sir seems to be a darkmoon blade
since she uses the darkmoonblade spell
which can only be acquired by those a
part of the covenant but yorshka the
leader of said covenant states that
we'll be the only knight in the group if
we join furthermore sierra says that she
is a former servant of the divinity
which may imply that she was a dark moon
blade but left some time later as for
why she left it seems to be related to
the two people we fight against
throughout her questline who are
creighton and hodrick creighton is the
same one from dark souls 2 although this
does not imply that he was the canon
winner between him and pate as this was
probably thousands of years ago and i'm
assuming that creighton is also
unkindled as he most likely was revived
alongside us sir says that creighton was
a part of the rosario's fingers a rival
covenant and one that she despises and
hodrick seems to be her grandfather the
reason we know this is because she calls
out to him before the fight and when
defeated she says that she's pleased
that her granddad can rest in peace
hodrick seems to have gone mad at some
point and sirius wanted to put him out
of his misery she has a short but sweet
questline and the family connection to
hodrick was quite the shock the question
still remains though what is the sunless
realms because her full name is cirrus
of the sunless realms it's nice to
speculate about it but there isn't much
information to go off of and this is a
running trend throughout the series and
personally something i'm not a fan of
there are so many locations in the game
that we learn about like astora kareem
katarina mira alkin venon so many more
but there's no in-depth lore about them
hell most of them don't even give us a
service level idea of what they're about
this is not a dark souls 3 issue and
more of a series issue as the devs have
been given three chances to develop some
of these places and from software has
just refused to do so many people
including myself have tried to speculate
on more details regarding these kingdoms
but there's so little to go off of that
it's not even worth it their inclusion
in the game was probably because the
team wanted to add a bit of flavor to
the world to not only show that the main
kingdom isn't the only kingdom in the
dark souls universe but also that people
from all over are flocking to this
kingdom in search of something important
it just feels like a wasted opportunity
to barely mention these places after
three whole games as a whole dark souls
3 has some great quest lines and i would
go as far to say that it's the most
polished out of the entire series dark
souls 3 recognized what was wrong with
the previous two entries and made sure
not to repeat those same mistakes again
with the npc's done we can now resume
our objective which as a reminder is to
defeat the lords of cinder and use their
ashes as kindling so that we may travel
to the kiln of the first flame and
relink the fire to do this though we
actually need five lords of cinder the
abyss watchers yorm prince lothric
aldridge and ludleth the reason i said
four earlier is because ludleth is
actually the only one who complies with
the rules as he's already at firelink
shrine when we arrive loveless throne
says that he was exiled from his
homeland the reason why he was exiled
was because of his art of transposition
for gameplay purposes this allows us to
take the boss holes and make weapons out
of them just like the pass games what's
odd though is that when he dies he drops
the skull ring which talks about a being
called the soul feeder and how it was
this insatiable beast that hungered for
souls due to the ambiguity of his past
it's led to many theories such as ludwig
being a soul feeder himself but was at
one point defeated which is why he has
no legs and possibly can't fit on his
throne it is also entirely possible that
loveleth is just someone who wants to do
the right thing and has no ill
intentions but the skull ring definitely
leaves a lot up to the imagination to
get to the other four lords we'll need
to use the bonfire at firelink shrine
which will take us to the high wall of
lothric and it is absolutely stunning
you're immediately greeted with an
entire view of the castle and it's a
breathtaking view but it's also an
illusion the kingdom of lothric is
riddled with corpses and those who
survived other became hollows or are
still seen defending a lifeless kingdom
lothric is governed by the three pillars
of rule the knights who protect the
kingdom the scholars who run the grand
archives and the high priestess who also
served as prince lothric's wet nurse
those who abide by these rules are the
lothric knights but these wingnite
variants are said to be heretics as they
don't accept their rules this is because
of gertrude the heavenly daughter in the
grand archives we can find a bird cage
cell with a dead body in it this is
assumed to be gertrude she was one of
the queen's holy maidens although
depending on some item descriptions she
may also have been her daughter one day
gertrude was visited by an angel and
through this was able to establish the
angelic faith of lothric seeing as this
isn't a part of the regular three
pillars gertrude was taken and
imprisoned those who agreed with her
teachings though banned together to
defeat the current rulers of lothric
which led to a massive civil war out of
all the three kingdoms we've visited so
far in the trilogy the kingdom of
lothric is easily in the worst state
this condition that we see the castle in
may also symbolize the world of dark
souls itself i'll elaborate more on this
idea later but it's my personal theory
that not only did our characters from
dark souls 1 and 2 link the flame but
every person in between these games did
so as well if we go back to the intro
the narrator says that lothric is where
the transitory lands of the lord's
converge meaning this isn't like the
past games in dark souls 1 all the main
bosses were within lordran already but
in dark souls 3 the lands of these lords
have been forced together it's unclear
how this is even possible but it may go
back to the first flame the world of
dark souls is dying it's a shadow of its
former self places are being buried
destroyed and created in an endless loop
the intro does a great job of showing
this but the one area that truly opened
my eyes to this was drag heap this place
is covered in rubble and buildings that
span so far and wide that you can't even
tell what the buildings used to be or
when they were built we talked about how
time was convoluted in dark souls 1 but
in dark souls 3 this has been progressed
even further lands are being moved
together creating a tidal wave of rubble
and it's all because the first flame if
you watched the past videos you may have
noticed how worse things have gotten
throughout the series and i believe this
is because the first flame hasn't been
snuffed out people are still clinging on
to that illusion of life as aldia put it
and are willing to stay in the comfort
of what they know rather than step out
into the unknown because of that the
world has gotten even worse each dark
souls game has tried to push the player
toward one specific idea the age of fire
in one the breaking of the curse in two
and the age of dark and three everyone
in dark souls 3 is just doing what they
continue to do because it's all they
know some are blindly following their
faith and others are continuing to work
on their craft this game truly conveys
the attitude and the effects of a dying
world one that is practically begging to
be put out of its misery it's basically
saying look at all of this in-game look
at the destruction of the kingdoms the
ruins of the world and the people who
inhabit it do you think any of them are
truly happy to be alive right now not
even the lords of cinder beings who have
insurmountable power don't even want to
link the flame it lays all of this out
for you and asks you to choose which is
quite a heavy burden choosing to go
against the status quo that has been
said for who knows how long is a very
hard decision but at least we don't have
to make that choice now as the game will
blindside us again and create another
boss encounter for us to be hypnotized
by we'll talk about it for later though
as he does have ties to another boss
later in the game after vort will be
taken to the undead settlement this
place functions like the undead burg in
dark souls 1 as this place was the
residence of many of the kingdom's
undead but one thing we'll see
immediately upon entry is this massive
pile of corpses at the end of the bridge
these beings are pilgrims that are most
likely from the kingdom of londor as the
only survivor is yole of londor he is
related to yuria however so we will have
to discuss him a bit later as we explore
the undead settlement we can see that
this place is in just as bad of shape as
lothric castle bodies are piled up
everywhere and some have even been put
into cages this land has also been
subjected to various curses and because
of this many of the settlements
inhabitants sealed them away in a spirit
tree but would end up cursing the tree
itself which would lead to the creation
of the cursed rotted great wood during
the second phase the great wood will
slam into the ground and will discover
the true resting place of all the
settlements hollows in the aptly named
pit of hollows it's unclear though
whether or not the hollows that were
dumped here were alive or not upon
arrival but since the mound maker's
covenant is down here it's possible that
they were thrown in here alive and all
fought to the death which would explain
the plethora of bones covering the walls
but it could also be that these people
actually banded together to create the
mound maker's covenant regardless it's
clear that their fates were sealed the
moment they were thrown in while the
curse rotted great wood is to the left
of the dilapidated bridge if we instead
go to the right we'll make it to the
road of sacrifices and subsequently
fairing keep which leads us to our first
lord of cinder the abyss watchers fair
and keep is rather interesting as not
only is it the resting place for the
abyss watchers but it may also be the
ruins of oolacile in this area we can
find the golden scroll and the dusk
crown items that have ties to oolacile
and we can also find dead mushrooms and
maybe even the final resting place of
elizabeth if this taller mushroom is
assumed to be her this would also fit
narratively with the abyss watchers as
they were a part of an organization
dedicated to fighting the abyss and
seeing his manus was located under
oolacile this would tie together quite
nicely the abyss watchers were the main
fighting force of a group called the
undead legion of pharyn who took
inspiration from artorius and dedicated
their lives to fighting the abyss but
their group numbers seem to be much
larger than they seem as these monstrous
beings are seen guarding the abyss
watchers boss arena they even managed to
recruit one of the twin crystal sages
that is said to have betrayed his
scholarly friends of the grand archives
to ally with the undead legion as for
the abyss watchers themselves it said
that they all shared the blood of the
wolf most likely in reference to this
wolf found in the area and used its
blood to increase their power and their
power was unmatched as not only were
they able to hunt together like a pack
of wolves but they've been known to bury
an entire kingdom at the slightest sign
of the abyss this group would eventually
link the flame presumably an attempt to
cast away the abyss for good but with
their main force gone the rest of the
forces dwindled and left the undead
legion as there was nothing else to do
but as we know the abyss can't be
destroyed that easily it eventually came
back and went unchecked since none of
the legion were around and managed to
turn their land into a festering swamp
these monstrosities that we see may have
been legion soldiers who were corrupted
by the abyss when the abyss watchers
awoke they came to the realization that
their home was overrun and their mission
was unsuccessful and while it's not
stated when this happened at some point
some of the members became tainted with
the abyss itself which leads to the
cutscene before the boss fight where
they're all fighting one another as
they're trying to fight back against the
abyss but since they're all undead
they're constantly being revived so
they're stuck in this never-ending
battle between each other which is
likely why they won't link the flame
doing it the first time didn't stop the
abyss and they have more important
things to do than sit on their throne
and let the abyss consume the world i
absolutely love the abyss watchers and
not just from a lore perspective but
also as a boss what really sold the
fight for me was the hints of artorias
that were spread throughout their move
sets the undead legion took inspiration
from artorias so it's only right that
they mimic his fighting style and the
fast-paced leaping attacks that they
have really reminded me of that fight
furthermore this fight's quality
increases tenfold once the other members
join in as it turns this honorable duel
into this chaotic mess you lose all
focus during this fight as you're having
to keep track of three different abyss
watchers who can slide across the arena
in a second and the second phase is just
as deadly as the last dead abyss watcher
consumes the blood of all his brethren
in a last-ditch attempt to stop us he's
a lot faster than last time and produces
flames from his sword which makes the
fight even harder it shows how dedicated
the group is to their mission and how
they'll use anything they can as long as
they win similar to how artorias fought
us with all his strength and even a
broken arm from both a presentation and
gameplay perspective the abyss watchers
are fantastic lords of cinder and the
best way to introduce the player to the
sheer power these lords hold behind the
abyss watchers is the catacombs of
karthus a place that has seemingly no
actual kingdom as this karthus is never
seen in game but given that wolnir is
located down here and is known to be a
lord consumed by the abyss maybe the
abyss watchers leveled the entire
kingdom and while that is an interesting
idea to think about what's more
important is actually what's underneath
the catacombs if we break this bridge
and use it as a ladder we can enter the
smoldering lake the original location of
lost izalith and possibly ash lake in
here we can see giant structures that
look very similar to arch trees of ash
lake and given the geography of lordran
ash lake and lost izalith weren't too
far from one another so it wouldn't be a
stretch to assume that they can exist in
the same location if we continue deeper
into the lake we'll see dozens of dead
demons that resemble the capra taurus
and stray demon from dark souls 1. it's
very clear that the demon race is dying
and that they're struggling to survive
we can even see this in this stray demon
near fair and keep which is covered in
stone rather than the flesh and blood
that we're used to there's even the old
demon king whose balsam is covered in
the corpses of his fellow demons he'll
try his best to fight the ashen one with
all his might but most of his power ran
out years ago and as a last resort will
release all his flames in a fiery
explosion but in doing so he'll lose all
the power he's ever consumed and will be
unable to fight the demons of dark souls
3 are a dying race and further adds to
the theme of death and decay the game is
trying to convey kingdoms aren't lavish
spectacles of beautiful architecture
they're a war zone and the demon race is
no longer a formidable foe just a dying
breed that won't last another generation
the symbolism of this place is beautiful
as it shows that everyone is being
affected by the progression of time and
no one is gaining from having this age
continue but not everything needs to
have a sad ending as if we explore the
rest of the smoldering lake we can find
the corpses of a spider and a woman and
judging from the tone that is located on
her body it seems that quelana found the
fair lady and got to spend their last
moments with one another it's a
wonderful and happy ending quelana got
to find her sister who she thought was
dead and the fair lady is finally able
to die and no longer has to suffer
anymore getting back on track to get to
our next lord of cinder we need to find
irithyll but to gain entry we need to
find a specific item that is located in
the cathedral of the deep the resting
place of aldrich saint of the deep
aldridge's story is by far the most
vague but also the most detailed amongst
the lords of cinder as his story
encompasses various other bosses that
we've already had the pleasure of
meeting years ago aldridge was a common
cleric but he would eventually start
experiencing visions of a deep sea this
deep sea was another form of the abyss
and it was located in the lowest
possible depths imaginable and formed
the core components of the world we
never get to see the deep sea in game
but it seems to be the lowest layer
something only aldrich can see he then
shared this info with only those he
trusted who were his archdeacons
mcdonnell royce and klimt they not only
kept this information within their inner
circle but also encouraged one of
aldridge's insatiable urges whether this
was something he always had within him
or it came about when he saw visions of
the deep aldrich had an insatiable urge
to consume human flesh the archdeacons
encouraged this behavior and used their
influence to create an army of followers
to not only worship aldrich but also
went out and gathered sacrifices for him
that's why these evangelists are located
in the undead settlement as they are
trying to bring the undead to the
cathedral so that they may be consumed
by aldrich we also learned that he would
eat anyone even including children as
anri and horus are said to be the only
two children who managed to escape
aldridge's grasp where henri and horus
are located happens to be the road of
sacrifices the path that these settlers
and evangelists took to get to the
cathedral before consumption this
cathedral performed all manner of
rituals and cleansings in order to
purify those who entered its doors after
numerous sacrifices the people around
aldrich managed to go insane and even
though aldrich himself was able to keep
his sanity his form would change rapidly
as he would eventually become the black
sludge that we see in the intro due to
his immense power he was used as a lord
of cinder but seeing as aldrich was
fully consumed by the visions of a deep
sea linking the fire would be the
opposite of what he had planned so this
implies that it was linked against his
will they would eventually return
aldridge's body to the cathedral to be
placed inside the large coffin scene in
the deacons of the deep boss fight these
deacons were led by the archdeacons we
discussed earlier but while aldrich was
laying in his coffin another piece was
added to the board pontiff sullivan was
a former resident of the painted world
of ariandel just like the world of dark
souls the painted worlds have their own
cycles that need to be rekindled in a
sense well the pontiff lived in the
current painted world of ariandel but
felt no reason to continue his life here
as he had not experienced any hardship
or despair we'll learn about the
painting's residents in the dlc but
unlike the painted world of ariamis
which was a world for all the things the
gods feared ariandel was for those who
had nowhere else to go and are without
purpose sullivan would then set out in
search of a purpose and would eventually
come across the irithyll this place is
very relevant to the story as right next
to it is on orlando the same one from
dark souls 1. from various item
descriptions we learned that gwyndolin
didn't actually die in dark souls 1 as
he is still very much alive in this game
now whether or not the chosen undead
never fought him or they killed him but
he somehow revived himself is unknown
and ultimately irrelevant but with
gwyndolin being the only god left in
anor londo he tried to reach out to
those in his extended family in hopes of
trying to rebuild the god's rule the
only one he managed to find though was
yorshka a crossbreed girl similar to
priscilla it's unclear what her
relationship with gwyndolin was or even
her relationship with priscilla was but
all we know is that she was content with
helping gwyndolin in his objective
gwyndolin would also reinstate the
darkmoon blades as a way to help protect
them from any adversaries one of their
knights though happened to be pontiff
sullivan who infiltrated its ranks and
managed to corrupt all the members he
came across he would then end up
enacting his plan when gwyndolin was
stricken with an illness that left him
unable to care for his covenant or city
sullivan in one successful swoop managed
to imprison yorshka in a nearby tower
and throw gwyndolin inside an orlando
cathedral allowing him to have complete
control of earth which is how he earned
the title of pontiff in order to ensure
protection of his new kingdom the
pontiff would not only set irithyll
knights in various positions as guards
create a barrier over the whole city so
that no one could enter but also send
outrider knights to conquer other lands
we've already seen a few outrider nights
across the game already but the two most
notable knights are vort and the dancer
of the boreal valley not much is known
about the duo except the fact that the
dancer was a daughter from one of the
royal families in irithyll whether she
served willingly or not is unknown
either way both of their fates would end
up the same as they were both bestowed a
ring given by the pontiff which would
end up slowly turning them into these
malformed beasts after an unknown amount
of time aldrich would re-awake again as
a lord of cinder and would foresee the
world's eventual destruction at the
hands of the deep sea due to this
premonition though he would neglect the
throne and wait for the deep to overcome
the world and it was during this waiting
that he would dream of the old gods and
how they wanted to relink the flame he
saw this as a ploy against his own
wishes and sought to devour the very
gods he then traveled to irithyll
decimated the knights guarding the city
and forced the pontiff to surrender who
gave up control of anor londo allowing
aldridge to have an audience with
gwyndolin what happened next is what we
see during the boss fight we interrupt
aldrich mid-consumption who now has to
use the barely conscious body of
gwyndolin as a weapon to defeat us
aldrich seems to have very supernatural
powers as his soul when transposed can
give us the darkmoon longbow which
belonged to gwyndolin but also the
lifehunt scythe that belonged to
priscilla but interestingly though he
never consumed priscilla only dreamed of
her from what i can gather it seems that
aldridge can acquire abilities from
those he consumed and is also able to
peer into that person's memories the
reason he was able to acquire the life
on scythe is because it's a miracle
miracles and dark souls are like stories
you're essentially reciting a story and
using the talisman as a medium for the
power so aldrich consumed gwyndolin and
dreamt of priscilla during the
consumption and then learned the story
of the life on scythe and was able to
cast it since it's basically just the
equivalent of reading a story again
earlier i said aldrich had the most
detailed story out of the lords of
cinder and i wasn't lying his story
doesn't just include himself but five
other bosses and close to a dozen named
characters it is a very long story to
wrap your head around but it is the kind
of storytelling that got me interested
in these games in the first place it
showcases all the different events from
different points of view and how these
characters fit into one cohesive
timeline but just as the story is
detailed so too is it vague the deep
sits on a shelf alongside many of the
concepts of the dark souls universe that
are barely touched upon in its defense
though the deet does have a lot of item
descriptions tied to it so we can at
least get a better understanding of what
its true nature is but seeing as it's
never shown to us in game or ever
elaborated on further than what we
talked about it just becomes another
idea in the world of dark souls that
leaves a lot open to the interpretation
as for the boss fight aldrich was pretty
entertaining but i think a much better
boss fight in my opinion was pontiff
sullivan i've always liked sullivan's
design and plus the walk towards him is
always very ominous as you don't know
what to expect especially when he dashes
right at you the moment you get too
close ford and the dancer were pretty
much on the same level as aldrich in my
opinion i still think pontiff ranks
higher than all of them but they were
really entertaining fights and honestly
this opinion i have is pretty much the
same for most of the bosses in this game
even udyx was an entertaining fight and
he was the first boss we ever face it's
clear that the quality of the bosses has
been raised thanks to dark souls 3 and i
think one reason for this was because
the team reverted the previous ideas of
dark souls 2 and instead focused on the
quality again rather than the quantity
each fight brought some sort of unique
twist so that it never felt like you
were in some traditional fight as that's
what the enemies were for even fights i
dislike due to their lack of difficulty
like the deacons are still at least
mildly impressive as its leagues better
than the congregation from dark souls 2
which i'm assuming was the inspiration
for it those enemies between the bosses
are allowed to have basic attacks and a
combo or two but the bosses are where
all the creative talent is supposed to
be spilled into it felt like there was
real passion behind these bosses again
from their designs to their move sets
and that's one of the reasons dark souls
3 is held in such a high regard within
the franchise the other reason may also
be down to the locations themselves
there is beauty and destruction as they
say and dark souls 3 proves time and
time again how this is possible the
catacombs the cathedral and the
smoldering lake are all great examples
of this but the way the game shifts this
idea and instead showcases beauty
through architecture again through the
lens of things like irithyll and anor
londo is genius even the smallest things
like looking over a ledge and seeing the
rest of the kingdom or just walking
through the hallway that leads to gwyn's
tomb are beautiful not only because we
get to see some of these locations in a
new more updated light but because from
software has always expertly crafted its
levels to showcase these moments for us
that's one of the reasons anor londo was
so beloved amongst the community is not
only was it the first area that showed
actual signs of life in the world of
lord jam but its design was a sight to
behold even anor londo in its current
state still holds that beauty it's just
a different kind of beauty not how
various pieces of architecture can
create a god-like city that people can
only dream of but how despite its
destruction and loss of life anor londo
still manages to be a beacon of light
and upholds the massive significance
that it displayed in dark souls 1. after
the defeat of aldrich if we retrace our
steps back to irithyll we can find a
separate path that leads to the profaned
capital ruled by yorn the giant
interestingly though we don't just
arrive in the capital as upon exiting
through this hole in the wall we arrive
in the irithyll dungeon this place is a
massive and convoluted prison filled
with all manner of beings who have been
imprisoned and tortured and abused by
all the jailers these jailers are said
to hail from the profane capital but
later served under the rule of pontiff
sullivan they're also very ruthless in
their methods when it comes to subduing
skbs as they have a poisonous mist that
saps your health away and use a
scoldering piece of hot iron that not
only burns at the touch but will hinder
your ability to run away as you
temporarily fat roll when afflicted if
you manage to escape the prison you'll
be greeted by the underground city of
the profaned capital from a pure
spectacle or design perspective i think
shulva had a much better greeting upon
its entry but the profane capital is
still nice to look at it is admittedly
quite small this could once again be due
to the geological shift of the lands
towards lothric but that doesn't ignore
the fact that the devs could have done a
bit more with its design you'll likely
spend more time in the adjacent dungeon
than in the actual capital while the
area does lack in length it does try to
circumvent the issue a bit by adding a
bit more depth the capital is covered in
various trinkets goblets and burned
corpses and these bodies don't just stop
at the entrance they are in every
section of the capitol they're trying to
get the player to wonder what exactly
happened here well the capital was under
attack by a new flame called the
profaned flame this was a curse created
by a group of women and while they did
become disfigured and turn into these
creatures we see just outside the
capital they did manage to win in the
end as it pretty much killed every
single person who resided in said
capital but this is where gorm came in
as he attempted to stop this profane
flame before it caused any damage by
linking the flame and becoming a lord of
cinder but it didn't work as the
aforementioned destruction followed
shortly after the main question
surrounding it though is why do these
women create such a thing and how well
it's possible that it may have ties to
the abyss as both carla the witch and
the profaned cole who are both found in
the irithyll dungeon have ties to the
abyss
you're here to save me
but i'm guilty
a wretched child of the abyss
the words
did you happen upon this coal
this is much too dark
i see the abyss in it
furthermore we need to look at the
pontiff and elianora pontiff carries a
sword called the profaned greatsword
which states that sullivan discovered an
unfading flame below the tundra of
irithyll in the axe elianora can be
dropped from these monstrous creatures
which says that the women who triggered
the curse were relatives of a certain
oracle these words tundra irithyll of
land covered in snow and oracle all
point to elaine lois and alsana being
this oracle from what we just talked
about regarding the smoldering lake and
what we know from the old chaos and a
lamb lois it's clear that the flame of
chaos is dying so maybe this is an
altered version of the flame of chaos or
at least maybe the last few sparks of it
it's definitely a stretch but the
profane flame has always been
interesting to me as the last time a new
flame was mentioned in the series
well we kinda know how that went upon
his revival though yorm saw the state of
his city and was in utter shock at what
had occurred so now he sits in despair
unwilling to link the flame but despite
how depressing it would be to kill him
we not only need his ashes but a friend
also needs to uphold his promise
yom
old friend
i
secret of the knights of katarina
have come to uphold my promise
let the sun shine upon this lord of
cinder
when jordan became the ruler of his
kingdom many of the people disapproved
of him in an effort to gain their trust
he created two weapons called the storm
rulers and gave one to his people should
he ever step out of line and the other
to his best friend siegward who promised
to kill him should he come back to life
this is also the final step in secret's
questline and was the main reason i
enjoyed it so much as being able to
fight alongside an npc such as him
against a giant sounds like a blast but
despite the wonderful presentation and
design of yorm's character it's easily
the most underwhelming fight in the game
using the storm ruler is the only way to
do real damage to the arm the main
attack of the storm ruler is the weapon
art that produces a slash of wind
capable of downing him but that's just
it it's just the same move over and over
again doing this alone is easy and with
secret it becomes even easier as you can
almost unlock your home for a large
portion of the battle and for this to
occur during a fight with a lord of
cinder is pretty pathetic on top of this
yarm's second phase doesn't really
change anything it just adds a bit of
fire to his weapon i feel like there was
much more potential for yorm but it was
never given to us thankfully this
wouldn't be the last time this idea
would exist in a souls game as eldon
ring repurposed this idea and it was
much better handled there our final lord
of cinder is prince lothric the one who
started this problem in the first place
but the real question is why it's the
one thing that's been rattling in my
head since the very beginning why did
lothric refuse to link the flame well
the answer is honestly a bit sad prince
lothric was born to die the rulers of
lothric were king osiris and his queen
osiris had three children named lorian
lothrich and ocelot lorian was the first
and was a formidable soldier on the
battlefield who was able to
single-handedly defeat the demon prince
who was said to rule over all the demons
osiris figured that his lineage could
push their power even further by
creating a child specifically to become
a lord of cinder and lothric was to be
that child but he failed lothric wasn't
strong enough so the family committed a
deed so heinous that it cursed him for
life despite the curse though it worked
and lothrick was capable of relinking
the flame but his frail body combined
with his poor health left him bedridden
and resentful being the helpful brother
that he was elorian wanted to combine
his soul with lothrics but because of
lothric's curse it consumed lorian as
well which left him mute and a [ __ ]
due to this the current state of the
world and the fact that even his teacher
was having doubts about relinking the
flame it ultimately caused lothric to
refuse and honestly it's hard to blame
him being created for the sake of power
and not knowing what your sacrifice will
truly do is a hard burden to put on a
child especially when you consider how
much grooming was presumably done to get
lother ready to link the flame had even
brought up in a different light this
story could have been changed but due to
the greed of the king it ultimately
started a chain of events that would
bring about the end of the world at the
very least though the twin princes
weren't the only ones that suffered
osiris is more dragon than human now and
has gone insane because of it similar to
how big hat logan became deranged from
the knowledge he read on sith so too did
osiris and depending on what you believe
he may also be hallucinating during the
fight he talks about his son ocelot and
we can infer that he's carrying him in
his hand but nothing is there this
however may not be as obvious as it
seems there's currently two theories i
believe in that argue for and against
ocelot's existence on one hand ocelot
may be a hallucination from the king
either because ocelot died and he can't
accept the loss or that he had been
hallucinating the mere idea that he had
a child in the first place however on
the other hand ocelot may actually exist
but was removed due to some real world
complications during the second phase of
the boss fight osiris will scream
ocelot's name then slam the hand that
carries him into the ground presumably
killing him we can hear a baby crying in
the background during the fight implying
that he lived but i think this was a
loophole buy from software to get rid of
complaints killing kids in games if i'm
not mistaken will get a game banned just
about everywhere and from software has
honored this rule and rarely ever adds
kids their games to begin with the only
ones that come to mind are kuro and
sekiro and father gascoin's daughter in
bloodborne but his daughter is never
seen as we're forced to talk to her
through a wall and while crow does make
an appearance numerous times he is never
shown to be harmed there are three parts
in the game that kuro is actually cut
with something and each time it happens
we never actually see the real act it is
of course implied that he has suffered a
wound but it's never actually shown from
software most likely wanted to add
ocelot and his death to the game but
couldn't do to the possibility of the
game being banned personally i've always
been a fan of the four party and do
believe that the king is not
hallucinating and ocelot was meant to be
in the game because this also connects
to the king's current mindset as he is
going so insane that he doesn't even
realize the harm he's putting his child
in but to make matters worse while the
king was consumed by seath's writings on
immortality and the twins were currently
suffering through no fault of their own
the queen had just decided to leave she
disappeared quietly into the night from
the kingdom and was never seen again the
queen's identity though is unknown but
it is heavily theorized to be gwynevere
from dark souls 1 we know that guinevere
bestowed divine blessings to her people
and was seen as a symbol of bounty and
fertility because of it and the divine
blessing of dark souls 3 says that the
queen of lothric was initially revered
as a goddess of fertility and bounty but
the issue is that we know that she left
anor londo and became the wife of a
flame god flan so how did she go from
him to osiris and why did she leave him
and come back here furthermore if
gwyndolin was actually trying to get the
gods back in anor londo how did the two
never find one another and why didn't
gwenevere come back this could have been
due to the presence of aldrich and the
pontiff within the cathedral but this
also calls into question rosaria as her
soul can create the bountiful sunlight
miracle which is one of the miracles of
gwynevere and given the presentation of
both characters from the room's layout
to their positions on the bed it's clear
that there is a connection between the
two whether rosaria is actually
guinevere or simply someone guinevere
knew is never explicitly told to us and
really in the grand scheme of things it
doesn't really matter but it is a very
interesting theory nonetheless it's
clear though to no one's surprise that
the royal family is in disarray and is
currently suffering just like the
kingdom is despite this though the
knights of the kingdom still stay strong
and continue to defend the castle
against the corruption that is the pus
of man but it's starting to fight back
as the puss of man is embedded within
these twin wyverns and many of the
castle soldiers and it seems like the
pilgrims of londor have also started
advancing on the castle as they've
managed to control the armor of the
dragon slayer and use it as a tool of
their destruction after battling through
all of this chaos though we can finally
meet the prince himself the twin princes
actually go against the status quo of
the game not just in their decision to
refuse the throne but also in how
they're presented to the player lothric
in a way is this game's gwyn or vendrick
he's clearly not on the same level as
the other two but it was lothric's
choices that set the game's plot into
motion just like how gwyn and vendrick's
choices set their games blocked into
motion instead of being presented as a
shambling corpse lothric is the opposite
even if he's just some bedridden child
that's cursed with a lifelong illness
the boss fight isn't this sad encounter
that makes you feel like you're doing
them a service by putting them out of
their misery you're fighting a being who
is extremely powerful and is fully
conscious of their actions as opposed to
the hollow versions of the other two it
was a wonderful twist as i expected to
be greeted by a somber tune all while
seeing the death and decay that has
continued to spread throughout the
kingdom reached the prince's chambers
but i didn't and that surprised me and
now is probably a good time to correct a
previous statement of mine a couple
months ago i made a review on dark souls
3. it was a bit more gameplay-centric
than this video is but in that video i
said despite loving the twin princes
lorian had always pissed me off due to
his awful teleportation ability and i
want to rectify that statement as i
never felt these feelings this time
around in the previous video on dark
souls 2 i talked about how the quality
of these bosses will always be a
subjective opinion as the boss's
enjoyment largely depends on the build
and the skill of the player i naively at
the time did not take this into
consideration and never considered that
i was the problem looking at the
gameplay now is downright embarrassing
and i realized that lorian was never the
issue it was me yes his teleport move
does occasionally break line of sight
which is still annoying but everything
was not as bad as i'd made it out to be
i always liked the twin princes as a
boss fighter that opinion has never
changed but i think i can now officially
say that it's not only the best lord of
cinder fight in the game but it's easily
one of the few fights in dark souls 3
that i consider completely perfect the
sheer presence of these two is amazing
the fight is pretty much lorian vs the
player lothric is able to protect lorian
with magic and heal him once he dies the
same way the player can heal with estus
and use their equipment to aid them
lothric is like the support role in this
duo but he's also the main character
that needs to be defeated as he can
obviously revive lorien but his magic
forces the player to not engage them
prolonging the fight even longer than it
already is giving lauren enough time to
finish us off and the fact that the duo
manages to be a threat no matter the
distance always adds to the intensity of
the fight i've always been one to admit
when i'm wrong and except the fact that
my opinions are never meant to be set in
stone and can always be changed and this
playthrough thoroughly changed my mind
about this fight as the twin princes are
not only worthy of the title lord of
cinder but were such an excellent boss
to put at the end of the journey
out of all the souls games i ended up
talking about these bosses the most out
of any in the trilogy and this is due in
part to the lord of cinders being the
only objective in the game so talking
about them is really all we can discuss
they are the main focus of the game and
thus need to have detailed lore to back
it up this was forgivable in the other
games as while those beings did have
some importance in the world they
weren't the main focus but in dark souls
3 they are if it wasn't for the lords of
cinder we wouldn't have a game so they
ended up becoming the main focus of the
story and the devs managed to deliver
aldrich is a testament to that statement
as i may have spent more time on them
than any character in the series with
the exception of the witch of izalith
who coincidentally also had numerous
bosses and characters tied to her plot i
was really impressed by the overall
presentation of this game especially
when it came to our four lords of cinder
even including yorm who had a wonderful
design and presentation despite the
fight being a bit lackluster their lore
was rich with details and the item
descriptions were long enough to create
an essay's worth of information but also
left enough info out to keep that soul
spirit of finding the context clues and
filling in the gaps plus the encounters
with said bosses made the time spent
getting to them worth it even yorm as
once again despite being disappointing
there was at least an attempt to create
the spectacle of tackling a monolithic
sized giant but if there was one thing
that bothered me about this game it was
the lack of attention given to dark
souls 2. narratively this actually fits
quite well as drang lake was supposed to
be seen as this unimportant kingdom that
would be easily toppled and replaced
with something else in time only to be
forgotten by the rest of the world but
if the point was to make the kingdom
feel unimportant why are there constant
references to it like creighton
appearing in cirrus's quest lucatiel's
armor and aslatiosword resurfacing in
the game the dead giant at firelink
shrine and not only a portrait of
nashandra but of a liam loyce and broome
tower found in irithyll it just feels
confusing it's like the team actively
wants the player to know that despite
not making dark souls 2 they are aware
and care about the game but barely put
in the effort to justify it what is
truly the most upsetting part about this
is that both vendrick and aldia to my
knowledge are never mentioned once
throughout the game there is one magic
spell found in the grand archives that
says the words the first of the scholars
which many people have pointed towards a
link to aldia but he was a scholar of
the first sin not a first scholar plus
the first of the scholars could refer to
the scholars of the grand archives not
aldia it's a shame because they were the
only beings that we know of who sought
to break the curse through
unconventional means and there's zero
remnants of their work the two are never
brought up in the game and the actual
structures of drangleic or altius keep
are never seen in game i understand that
dark souls 2 is not everybody's cup of
tea and maybe the original team wanted
to do away with the beat team's creation
but you can't deny that vendrick and
aldia had the potential to create a
sizeable impact on the story and for
their legacy to be tarnished like this
is a bit disappointing with all the
lords of cinder dead and their ashes
within our inventory we can now link the
first flame but before we do that there
is two dlc's and a couple other bits of
content from the main areas that i want
to address first if we rewind and go
back to osiris and visit the area behind
his boss arena we'll uncover a place
called the untended graves this place is
identical to the cemetery of ash in the
beginning of the game with the only
difference being the lighting it's one
of the most talked about locations
within the community as this confusion
coupled with this feeling of nervousness
settles in as upon entry you start to
recognize all the familiar landscapes
and are just bewildered that a place
like this even exists the boss is also
identical as its champion gundyr as
opposed to utics according to his boss
description champion gundyr came to
firelink shrine to relink the fire but
failed and arrived too late he was then
eventually bested by an unknown warrior
and given the series have a use of that
term we can assume that this warrior was
us afterwards he then became a she for
the coiled sword so similar to oolacile
and the memory of the giants we can go
back in the past kill champion gundyr
who then becomes a sheath for the coiled
sword and hopes another warrior will
come and use it to link the flame who
just happens to be us we then take the
sword from his present body as udyk's
gundyr and use it at the bonfire if we
happen to defeat champion gundyr though
we'll be greeted with an identical
firelink shrine and while the fire
keeper is not here there are an eyes of
a fire keeper located inside the
building if we have the eyes in our
inventory ludleth and the firekeeper
will comment on them loveth refers to
the fire keeper as her implying that he
knows the identity of this person and
the fire keeper will mention how these
eyes reveal frightening images of
betrayal in a world without fire so we
can assume that this was in the past and
since ludwig is familiar with the fire
keeper and is a lord of cinder it's
possible that this was during the time
he linked the fire which would also
connect with the intro of the game that
says that the land of lords are
converging together this line just
happens to be ludleth's but what doesn't
make sense is the handmaid's dialogue as
in the dark firelink shrine her attitude
seems to imply that the flame is still
lit as she tells us to hurry along but
how is this possible well sadly i don't
have an answer for that the untended
graves is one of the hardest parts of
this game to wrap your head around which
makes discussing it extremely difficult
one explanation though could be that the
fire keeper's eyes are what's causing
this darkness as the world in
present-day dark souls 3 is getting
close to the age of dark as evidenced by
the giant dark sign eclipse in the sky
but there's still plenty of light left
in this world whereas in the untended
graves there's nothing but if all the
lights extinguish and that implies that
this is an age of dark but ludlow think
the flame and continue the age of fire
so that's why i think it's the eyes of a
fire keeper displaying a vision in the
sense of what the world would come to
should we enact this grand betrayal
which is letting the flame die out
another thing of note though is the
repair spell in dark souls 3 which says
that light is time and the reversal of
its effects is a forbidden art so this
implies that the untended graves could
be like the things betwixt it sort of
stuck in limbo because there's no light
existing and therefore time not existing
regardless this but it's very confusing
backstory it's probably my favorite
location to discuss in the game as
there's so many possibilities as what
this place truly means
the final location is near irithyll
dungeon as we can use the dragon pose
from the untended graves to be
transported into arc dragon peak we
already know that immortality via dragon
form is not unheard of as many people
worship the stone dragon in dark souls 1
osiris is assumed to be human before he
became a dragon and we can actually find
some dragon stones which will turn us
into a humanoid dragon similar to the
one sitting next to us so it's pretty
safe to assume that this place was used
to worship the ancient dragons despite
the fact that they're all dead now but
even though they're all dead that
doesn't mean the other flying types
won't exist as we get to challenge a
wyvern shortly after arriving which at
first glance is a pretty cool fight
until you realize that the enemies on
the walkways are actually tougher than
the boss itself i can recognize that the
team was most likely experimenting with
some bold ideas for boss fights and
while it's definitely cool at first it
just feels a bit unnatural if you will
as completely destroying its health bar
in one plunge attack just felt off arc
dragon peak not only has a questionable
first boss but also raises various
questions that admittedly may leave
people confused two characters have
arrived at this location at certain
points in time which are havil and
ornstein we find havel next to a downed
dragon and we find ornstein's armor
towards the end of the level i can
forgive havel for being here since he's
always had a hatred for dragons and
seats since dark souls 1 but that
doesn't explain how he's alive while
havel had a band of knights who followed
him and more than likely wore the same
armor as he did so i don't think this is
havel more just a night of havel but
while this is explained fairly easily
ornstein is not ornstein has always had
a complicated history within the series
as he was clearly present in dark souls
1 but then shows up again in dark souls
2 as the old dragon slayer and then
again in this game as the dragon slayer
armor and in arc dragon peak where we
are now firstly i've always been a firm
believer in the fact that we kill
ornstein in dark souls 1. the old dragon
slayer is simply someone who is trying
to uphold ornstein's legacy or is
somehow connected to ornstein's soul
since we know from dark souls 2 that the
old lord souls can inhibit other's
bodies so it's possible orenstein's soul
inhibited someone wearing his armor it's
also possible that the soul felt
comfortable with this decision given
orenstein's armor is pretty synonymous
with his legacy as for dark souls 3 we
know that the dragon slayer armor is not
ornstein it is simply just another
dragon slayer as the weapon and armor
are completely different but arc dragon
peak is unique this is not only the same
armor that orenstein wore but its item
description talks about how he left the
anor londo cathedral to come here but
when did this happen he couldn't have
came here and then went back to the
cathedral as his armor is located here
and he couldn't have left after dark
souls 1 because he died so the only real
explanation that makes any plausible
sense is that ornstein dies in dark
souls 1. he then has his soul return
like the previous lord soul wears but
decides to inhabit someone wearing his
armor or maybe even the armor itself as
it's familiar to the soul we talked
about in dark souls 2 how it seemed like
the four great ones were connected to
specific lord souls because of their
feelings and emotions we still don't
know whether or not these lord souls
connected with them because of these
similar emotions or if they gain these
feelings from consuming the souls but if
this is true then it would make sense
that ornstein is continuing to fight the
same and has the same goals and
ambitions across all the games
regardless of how orenstein is alive or
how we even ended up here in the first
place we at least know why he was here
and that was because of the nameless
king the nemesis king has actually been
t since dark souls 1 as he was the
infamous firstborn son of gwyn that was
referenced in various items in that game
from both 1 and 3 we can piece together
that the nameless king is the firstborn
son of gwyn and was a dragon slayer
during the war with the everlasting
dragons but at some point he would
eventually cast all this away and ally
himself with the dragons and if you want
to talk about presentation when it comes
to boss fights this one needs to be
mentioned not only does the introduction
of the boss feel intense as the nameless
king swoops in on a storm drake but when
we finish the drake off he literally
kills it and takes the power for himself
from just a pure gameplay perspective
he's easily the second best fight in the
game there's a feeling that occurs
across the entire series when everything
comes together you've learned the
moveset understood the timings and
discovered the punishes all that's
required is to put it together and when
that clicks it becomes one of the best
fights in the game his moves are
punishing have delays and are even mixed
together as one combo might have two
swings but the next will be three or
will do away with the third swing and
had a completely different move the
fight requires complete concentration
and the ability to be patient dodging
too early will more often than not lead
to your death so you have to be on high
alert for the whole fight genuinely a
great fight from top to bottom with it
only being surpassed by one being we
have yet to cover but before we move on
to the dlc i want to look back at the
game so far dark souls 3 set out to
create a dying world that features
places that have been ridden with
disease and death showing to the player
that their inability to let go of what
they know and continue this age of fire
will only make things worse even a basic
understanding of the lore will convey
this as you can see just how bad
everything has gotten from the fact that
there's hundreds of dead bodies that are
throughout each level and people are
becoming corrupted and infected with
these diseases and plagues causing them
to either go hollow or turn into a
massive black sludge the demon race a
group of beings thought to be on top are
dying out the gods have all been wiped
out and the lords of cinder beings who
have the ability to rule over anything
they please due to their power refuse to
continue this age of fire aldrich wants
to continue his own age so admittedly
that is a bit more selfish but the other
three have recognized that their
sacrifice did or will amount to nothing
linking the flame never stopped the
abyss and never stopped the profane
flame and it's never going to end the
suffering that's occurred since lordran
so the first flame is supposed to be
this symbol of peace and comfort then
what is actually so good about it all
this has been illustrated to us
throughout the story and is a testament
to how genius the writing of dark souls
3 truly is
but now it's time to move on not just to
a new ages that will come later but to a
new world a painted world even this old
man in front of us is gail and he's how
we start the dlc ashes of ariandel we
talked about this place briefly when we
discussed pontiff sullivan and said it
was a painted world for those without
purpose upon entering we're greeted by a
deformed being who welcomes us and tells
us to get comfortable on a bed of rot
similar to the real world the painted
worlds have their own cycle and it's
this cycle that is so interesting as in
the main game the age of fire is being
constantly prolonged and it's the age of
dark that will take it over but as we'll
soon see it's the rot that's being
prolonged and the only way to get rid of
it is to burn it the painted world of
ariandel is just a similar version of
the dark souls universe with the same
themes and ideas just twisted around
they're both separate worlds with
separate cycles and each one has a
particular cycle that is going on too
long and it's either the fire that's
causing it or the fire that will get rid
of it this is also the reason gail sends
us to the painted world in the first
place as opposed to the corvian we meet
first who tells us to embrace the rock
gale and even this corvian settler want
us to set it aflame setting the painting
of flame will allow a new painted world
to be created but they can't do that
without fire and the person preventing
this is sister freed she is the reason
the rot is being prolonged and she's
also the other ash that the gale and the
corvian refer to meaning she's unkindled
it's because of her decision to keep the
rock going that has caused much of the
destruction of this place interestingly
though only the corvians seem to care as
we talked about the painted world is for
those without purpose and the corvians
aren't the only ones who reside here as
these soldiers are the members of the
undead legion of pharyn in the beginning
of the video when we talked about the
abyss watchers i mentioned that when
they linked the flame the rest of the
legion left once that occurred the
others no longer had a purpose and
further lost any chance of having one
once they came to the realization that
their home had turned into a swamp
according to their armor these pharan
followers seem to be specifically tasked
with killing any undead legion who
succumbed to the abyss which makes me
wonder how the abyss watchers cutscene
would have played out had the assassins
not left maybe the abyss watchers would
have finally been able to regain their
strength again now that they didn't have
to kill each other the other group of
people are the millwood knights they
don't have too much lore and anything to
really tie any of the characters or
events to them but at some point in time
they lost their forest that they called
home and then sought refuge in the
painted world these groups seem to just
carry on throughout their day and simply
exist within the painted world but the
corvians are different as you have the
regular looking settlers who want to
burn the rod away but then there's also
the corvian knights who were so
infatuated with sister free that they
have now turned against their brethren
just the basic idea of what the painted
world represents to the people within it
is such an intriguing concept but the
way this loosely connects to the main
game's themes is genius one thing i
always found disappointing though about
ashes of ariendo was the length once we
enter the painting we're to meet with
sister freed who welcomes us but just as
quickly dismisses our arrival and tells
us to leave because we no longer belong
here i have no issue with this as it's
not holding the player's hand but
everything just feels like it's going so
fast as right after this we're to find
the painter enter the basement of sister
freed's church activate a lever and then
we're already at the final boss
everything just feels so fast and i was
surprised how quickly the final boss was
introduced to me i've talked about
before how most of the souls games dlcs
are like this and don't take much time
overall this of course though largely
depends on how fast you beat the bosses
as they're usually the main hurdles but
ashes of ariendo felt shorter than
normal there is an optional boss that
could take up more of your time but this
was just so that the player could access
the pvp matches and the lore of the boss
also connects to this as this was the
champion of the undead matches that the
undead used to partake in other than
that it's pretty much just going from
one area to the next and the distance
between them is quite short once we do
finish talking with sister frieda though
our path will eventually lead us to the
corvian settlements and its church where
we will meet with sir wilhelm he was the
guard that was outside the church where
sister freed was located but what's more
interesting though about sir wilhelm is
that he not only has a black flame buff
on his weapon but he also wields the
darkhand both of which have ties to the
abyss this relates back to sister freda
as she was one of the three sisters of
the sable church her other sisters were
lillian and yuria which means she has
ties to londor and this is reinforced by
the different dialogue options that we
get from her if we have the dark sigils
in our inventory from yuria's questline
it's not much but she does recognize us
as the lord of hollows given that she is
unkindled it's possible that she tried
to link the flame or usurpet and this
possibly got her exile from the church
without a purpose or home she may have
been drawn to the painted world which is
how she ended up here in the first place
and figured that she could rule over
this land by herself however given that
we have this innate ability to ruin
people's plans we're going to prevent
sister fred from doing so to do this we
need to talk to the painter and unlock
the doors leading to her room for her to
be able to paint though she will need to
see flame and to do this we need to get
to the source
bring
this is father ariendo the painter of
the painted world of ariandel who is now
being held captive by sister freda she
managed to convince father erie andel
that the only way to preserve the
painted world was to bury the flame and
let the rock consume the world to stop
it from spreading he uses his flail on
himself causing him to bleed which
appeases the flame it's quite a sad
story and it makes sister frida out to
be even worse of a person than she
already was given that we're going
against her wishes though she fights us
and she is very difficult which is also
very entertaining i love this fight and
i think it's a great way to end the dlc
the fight starts out quite normal until
her blood reaches father ariandel who
freaks out causing the room to be
engulfed in flames and him to break out
of his restraints and attack us fruit is
also back and it turns into a 2v1 it's
very reminiscent of ornstein and smoe as
the duo complements each other quite
well this is also the only fight in the
trilogy to my knowledge where you can
summon an npc in the middle of the fight
as gayle can only be summoned for the
second phase it also makes sense to
bring him along since both you and him
have the same objective so there's no
reason for him not to help you after
sister freda has been dealt with though
we can return to the page
[Music]
yeah so if it wasn't already bad enough
sister frida has a third phase this
whole encounter is extremely stressful
as you not only have to plan for one but
two extra phases there's been so many
times where i got pummeled during this
fight in the first phase that i just
reset as i knew it wasn't worth starting
the next phase with half the estus she
really forces the player to learn her
move set thankfully though gail does
make the encounter easier but is still
very difficult even with his assistance
with sister fred and father ariendel
dead for real this time the fire will
now be able to consume the painting
without any delays which means the
painter can now work on the new world
she plans to create a cold dark and very
gentle place as she calls it she's going
to need paint to make that painting and
from what we learn from father
eryandel's soul we know that the
paintings are written in blood so gail's
objective will be to scour the land for
some blood to use his pigment and while
he does that we can go on to the next
dlc but gail's here too he has written
messages for us and points us towards
where we're supposed to go so what blood
is he getting well gail is trying to
find the blood of the dark soul the dark
soul which leads him to the ring city
ashes of arianda was a short but decent
dlc the bosses were great and the actual
design of ariendo was beautiful from its
frozen tundras to its rotted swamps but
if it felt complete or if the dlc
suddenly ended so soon that's the point
as both of dark souls 3's dlcs are a
connected story the story of gale and
the painter and their quest to create a
new world which leads us to the ring
city the start of the ring city dlc sees
us travel to the drag heap the area we
talked about earlier in the video as i
said then time is getting worse as the
world progresses and this is a perfect
example as now that the age of fire is
getting even closer to the end lands are
converging on each other more and more
and the world is practically collapsing
in on itself here in the drag keep we
can see nostalgic call backs to the past
like the earthen peak windmill and the
desert pyromancer from dark souls 2.
this is a very long and convoluted level
to really showcase how bad everything
has gotten but at the very end of the
level is the demon duo not only is the
gameplay of this fight fantastic as it
not only surpasses the previous duo but
might even be on par as orenstein and
smoe but the location of the fight is
heavily theorized to be the original
firelink shrine of dark souls 1. the
reason being is that the exit of this
arena is the same structure that frampt
appears in gil can once again join you
for this fight but it will trivialize
this encounter tremendously as the
demons have long cooldowns between their
attacks and also alternate movesets i
actually found this fight to be balanced
while being outnumbered so adding more
people makes it worse once the demons
are both dead the last one to die gets
to be reborn as the demon prince just
like the first flame the chaos flame
needed to be rekindled by a demon with
vast power and the current demon prince
at the time was going to but ended up
facing lorian and was defeated however
all demons share memories with another
so in theory that means they can share
the power of the demon prince and when
the last demon falls it is reborn as the
demon prince and the last of its kind
the demon prince is a genuinely great
fight and for being the first boss in
the dlc this is already a great start to
the additional content when the demon
prince does fall though we can finally
say goodbye to the demons the once great
race thought to be almost on top has now
withered away never to be remembered
again just like everything else in this
world with the drake finished we can
move on to the final location of the dlc
but one thing that's been very
interesting about the drag heat was the
progression of time as we go further
down in the game we're actually going
further back in the past as we start out
at the very top in dark souls 3 we move
further down to dark souls 2 with the
earthen peak making an appearance and
then we're all the way at the bottom
where we're back in dark souls 1 with
the firelink shrine but we can go even
further back as past the old firelink
shrine we can travel to the ring city a
place that has existed since the gods
toppled the dragons the ring city is
gorgeous and is one of the most
beautiful locations in the dark souls
trilogy this place is home to the pygmy
lords and they have a wonderful
welcoming committee
oddly enough though these shadow archers
actually look like the ruined sentinels
from dark souls 2. according to their
armor set they were a band of knights
who were sent to the ring city so it's
possible that vendrick may have sent
them here as a way to find out more
about the undead curse but were defeated
and now are used by the city to defend
its people during city is the home of
the pygmies the ancestors of mankind we
don't hear much regarding the actual
furtive pygmy but the ring city is ruled
by the pygmy lords the early descendants
of the original pygmy according to
various item descriptions though gwyn
gave them this city as a reward for
their help against the dragons but since
this is located at the literal edge of
the world it's possible gwen wanted the
pygmies out of sight and away from his
kingdom since they had the dark soul
which of course he does not like as for
how the pygmies helped during the war
what we can find out soon after as these
ringed knights were some of the soldiers
who fought during the war with the
everlasting dragons the weapons they
carry were forged from the abyss since
that was the birthplace of humanity
which would explain the play in dark
sign on their chest as it seems that
they too were cursed like we were by
gwyn if we progress further into the
level we'll end up in this abyssal swamp
and end up fighting the dragon slayer
armor again and if we read its
description we'll discover that when we
defeated it in lothric it somehow made
its way down here and then became
possessed again by the feeling of battle
look i
love orenstein as much as the next guy
but we do not have to keep bringing him
back we can just let his legacy die i
understand in this case it is just a
piece of armor and not actually ornstein
but you have to admit that this boss's
design is purposely similar to
orenstein's i found this encounter more
annoying rather than interesting as
there was zero reason to bring back the
dragon's lair armor again in the swamp
we can also find a white face locus
similar to the one earlier in the level
these locusts are beings from the abyss
and they were supposed to pre-sermons to
men so that they could draw them towards
the dark but they couldn't see past
their stomachs and cared more about what
they were eating which is why they act
like gluttonous monsters this
description means that this is what they
always looked like and didn't turn into
these creatures at some point but it may
also imply that they were born alongside
humanity within the abyss each of them
ends up talking about specific people
and are possibly referencing certain
npcs
and so
she lived in fear
of the dark
of the things that gnawed at her flesh
the little creatures that nibble at me
in the darkness
and so
despite his weighty armor
he lived in fear
of a delicate thing
little more than a girl
where fire resideth shadows twist and
shrivel
but in the abyss
there are shadows none
fear not the dark my friend and let the
feast begin i've always found this
interaction odd as it's unclear how this
creature even knows anything about these
npcs this has caused a bit of debate
amongst many people in the community as
some claim that it's showing how
destructive humanity is but on the other
hand like with the case of irian his
dialogue the locus preacher could be
implying that the abyss is not as bad as
it seems as that preconceived idea
earing ahead of the abyss caused her to
feel these insect-like creatures in her
head i don't really think that there is
a correct answer here as it sort of ties
into the world of dark souls and how the
player views the abyss humanity and the
age of dark and whether or not it's
something that they should be embracing
similar to how we have to make a choice
at the end of the games before we leave
though we can view this purging monument
which is only accessible to humans as to
even get to this area we need to
transform into a humanity sprite using a
white tree branch this monument may be
the source of all the purging stones
printing stones have existed since dark
souls 1 and were used to remove the
curse effect in that game but it's not
about taking the curse and removing it
it's just transferring it to the stone
itself to be the new host but the stone
is said to once be a person so maybe
these are the beings who were turned
into stone or what they became once we
transfer the curse to the stone or maybe
it's something else entirely after
getting out of the swamp we'll find a
dragon named madeir this isn't fake like
the ancient dragon madeir is an actual
descendant of the arc dragons from long
ago even though he only seems to make an
appearance here if we knock him off the
bridge and find a secret tunnel we can
find him again he is easily the most
difficult boss in the entire game with a
staggering 15 000 health and he's also
equipped with some moves that might one
shot the player depending on their
equipment according to his boss soul
madeir was actually raised by the gods
and was tasked with fighting the abyss
and it seems that he's been alive for a
long time as one description says from
not long after the beginning meaning he
may have existed before even fire was
born back when the dragons ruled the
world the reason he's going so crazy is
very similar to artorias as the abyss
has fully corrupted him so we need to
put him out of his misery he is
definitely the ultimate challenge for
players given his kit of high damaging
moves but assuming you can conquer him
you'll receive the spears of the church
which ties into our next boss half-light
half-light is a member of the covenant
spears of the church who guards
phillianor who is said to be gwyn's
daughter who he left here in the ring
city but halflight is a pvp boss as
there's a chance a real player can
replace half-light and be the boss
instead but that is only accessible to
those who defeat media since he drops
the pendant that allows you to access
the covenant sadly though since this
game is over 6 years old you will more
than likely just get half light instead
interestingly though half-life may have
been from oolacile as the bow he uses
says that it was a relic from an ancient
land of sorceries that has been
swallowed by the abyss and we know that
oolacile has many unique spells like
repair hidden body and chameleon his
outfit also states that a group of young
missionaries went to the ring city long
ago but half-light stayed behind making
him the final spear of the church this
would also mean that there was a time in
ulysses history and when it wasn't
corrupted by the abyss and was a normal
land before koth came and tricked them
behind the church is filing or the girl
they swore to protect and she may have
one of the best cutscenes the series has
to offer upon touching her egg she wakes
up which sees the world change out of
everything in the dark souls series this
might be at the top as the most talked
about interaction in the game as there's
so much that happens with very little
explanation as to what it means many
people believe that filianore and her
egg held up the illusion of the ring
city similar to gwyndolin and anor londo
and dark souls 1 but some have also
claimed that this takes us to the future
and is a glimpse of what the world will
look like should we keep things going
her egg though is interesting as it has
a very dark center and if we relate this
back to the repair spell from earlier
that's as light as time by breaking the
egg we break the dark inside of it which
allows light to appear meaning now time
exists and is no longer stagnant which
would go along with the theory that this
is a future as the time accelerates
after being stagnant for so long
regardless of what you believe in though
this cutscene is great and allows us to
access the wasteland of ash inside this
wasteland is two beings and if you
subscribe to the theory that this is the
future this might be the last two beings
left in the world us and gail
what still here
handed over that thing
your dark soul
gail has not only gone mad and grown in
size but he is the final boss of the dlc
the ring city was the final dlc and also
the final piece of content in the dark
souls trilogy having played this game on
release i had already beaten the final
boss tons of time so for me gail was
technically my final boss of dark souls
and i couldn't have asked for anything
better to me gail is the best boss in
the game and even the entire trilogy
everything from design to presentation
to gameplay is completely perfect gael
is a slave knight who are knights that
were used as fodder in many of the
land's bleakest wars but it seems most
of them went hollow all except for gale
gill came to the ring city in search of
the dark souls and thus slaughtered the
pygmy lords as they contain the dark
souls within them since they're the
descendants of the furtive pygmy but
gail realized that the dark souls had
dried up so in order to make them liquid
enough to be used as pigment he consumed
the dark souls that they carried since
it was now in his bloodstream it was
able to mix into a liquid again but
doing so made him go mad gail literally
has the power of the dark soul within
his body and uses the power of the dark
soul and the abyss to fight us as
evident by these red skulls that appear
from his cape he and gwyn also contrast
each other in this respect gwyn was a
being who was a god from the beginning
and on top of the food chain and is
remembered by all for his sacrifice but
gail was a slave the lowest of the low
whose sacrifice will be known by only us
a lowly piece of unkindled ash this
sacrifice of gales ties into a theory of
mine after his death we can take the
blood of the dark soul to the painter to
be used as pigment for her new world
gail knew he wouldn't make it back but
continued his mission anyway by handing
it off to us he helps us defeat sister
freda and the demon prince which are the
two required bosses we need to beat to
get to the ring city and once we do get
to the ring city he leaves markings of
his cape along the way that it will
eventually point us towards his location
he wanted us to find him and he wanted
us to defeat him so that we can continue
his mission for him and give the painter
the blood she needed as a whole gail is
easily my favorite character and boss in
this game he is like us a nobody he
isn't some godlike figure or a being who
was born with insurmountable power he
like us gained this power through battle
and now the two strongest beings in the
world are duking it out at the edge of
the world truly the best boss this game
has to offer and was the best way to end
all the dlcs with gail defeated we can
now give the painter the pigment she
thanks us and will eventually start
painting she never actually finishes the
painting though and this is an important
detail just like the other dlcs in the
trilogy this isn't the end of the game
the final boss is at the kiln it's not
gayle so giving her this pigment doesn't
mean the end of the game it's just one
part of our long journey even if it
seems like a wonderful conclusion to the
game the dlcs of dark souls are the best
in the series and the ring city is a big
reason why ashes of ariandel is great
and a nice additional side story
especially since we get to learn more
about the painted worlds but the
callbacks references and answers to
questions we've been wondering about for
years are what makes this dlc so
impressive furthermore both dlcs have
some of the most intense fights in the
game and are the pinnacle of this game's
combat from software has always made
their dlcs with incredible quality and
sometimes are even better than the main
game and dark souls 3 continues to honor
this tradition
gale's objective is now complete so now
it's time to complete ours which is go
to the kiln and determine the fate of
the world once again defending this kiln
is being known as the soul of cinder
this is the physical manifestation of
every being to link the flame since its
inception meaning our characters from
dark souls 1 and 2 are a part of this
being he also fights like a real player
too as his moveset is by far the most
diverse in the game he has three
different melee weapons uses all the
schools of magic and even has the ninja
flipping from dark souls 1 but our old
characters aren't the only ones in this
being there is one other character we
know of the one who was here from the
very beginning he was the one that
created this world so it's ironic that
he gets to be here for when we destroy
it
so
[Music]
[Music]
the soul of cinder not only has the same
move set as gwen but also the same piano
and it's the music
i'll be honest i get a bit emotional
whenever i hear this hearing that piano
made me think of the journey i had taken
to get here all the defeats and
victories all the npcs i had encountered
all the kingdoms i uncovered and all the
fates of the people i've met along the
way we have seen the literal rise and
fall of the entire world before our eyes
and every single person and decision we
have made has shaped us into the person
we are now a person who now has to
determine the entire fate of the world
should you go against everything this
game has taught you and still believe in
the first flame you'll be shown a very
depressing ending the action one links
the flame and continues the age of fire
but it's not the spectacle we saw in
dark souls 1. it can barely even cover
our character let alone the rest of the
arena the ashen one looks disappointed
as if they expected something more in
fact we the player were probably
expecting something more and are now
just as disappointed this is why i
believe that everyone from gwen till now
has linked the flame when it faded as if
the world alternated like it was
supposed to then this wouldn't make
sense as to why the flame is this
pitiful the first flame is on its
deathbed and we still haven't granted it
the death it wants if we instead summon
the fire keeper she will take the first
flame and extinguish it for good the age
of dark will commence and the world has
gone completely black and while it may
seem scary to venture into a world
without fire the fire keeper assures us
that the fire will eventually return
someday just like it did all those years
ago remember things are meant to live
and die the age of dark is temporary and
fire will return and an age of fire will
begin again but hopefully it will not be
extended this time if you're feeling
greedy you can also enact the age of
dark and take the flame's power for
yourself this is similar to our final
ending and the secret ending of dark
souls 3 the usurpation of fire this
requires us to complete yuria's
questline yuria is from a place called
londor and we know that she's also the
sister of frida and lilian who created
the sable church and londor but what is
londor well it's a land of hollows as we
can see all the hollows bowing down to
us as the new lord of hollows londor
also had many pilgrims that came to this
land possibly to find the first flame
and overtake lothric those butterflies
from the dragon slayer armor are called
pilgrim butterflies so maybe this is the
pilgrim's final form so to speak these
pilgrims are most likely members of the
sable church as while the sisters
created the church the pilgrims most
likely went here to worship their god
who happens to be the primordial serpent
koth we never see koth in game and the
only reason we even know this is because
of yuri's death dialogue but the call
back to him was insane and almost maybe
nervous for a bit as he could have been
orchestrating this church for who knows
how long so that he finally gets what he
wants if you remember he tricked the
four kings and the people of oolacile
into being engulfed by the abyss so
what's stopping him from doing it
against the people of londor although in
his defense when we placed the lord
vessel in dark souls 1 koth says that
every last one of them failed him so
maybe he isn't trying to screw with
londor or impossibly found a genuine
group of people that will follow and
carry out his wish accompanying us into
the new world is also henri of astora
who depending on our actions either got
to defeat aldrich with us and finally be
able to kill the person she hated the
most or gets killed and unwillingly
serves as our bride when we become the
lord of hollows which is quite a dark
twist londor also seems to embrace its
hollow state but this may come at a cost
joel of londor can give us the dark
sigils required to progress the quest
line but once he does that he dies and
the assassin who gives us the wedding
sword dies after the ceremony so it
seems like they're only able to retain
their sanity when hollow but as a
consequence die once their purpose has
been fulfilled this is just about all we
know in regards to londor but there are
still quite a few theories involved with
the kingdom such as the fact that londor
could be tied to drawing lake or velka
admittedly it's a small connection but
items from dark souls 1 and 2 like the
vow of silence dead again dark drift and
dark hand have had their item
descriptions changed vow of silence in
dark souls 1 is a spell that was created
by velka but in dark souls 3 it's used
by members of the church and the dark
drift from dark souls 2 was said to be
used by the grave warden in the undead
crypt but in dark souls 3 it's used by
yuria however i don't think vendrick and
aldia are related to this though as the
two of them wanted to remove the curse
and londor wants to embrace their hollow
form although in a manner of speaking
the hollow form is the true version of
man and thus could be in a way what the
brothers desired but i'm not too sure i
believe in this theory especially given
how the brothers are never mentioned in
this game and would be weird if they
finally made an appearance now
regardless now it's time to say goodbye
to the age of fire and to dark souls the
age of dark is a metaphor for the dark
souls series every dark souls game has
taken place in the age of fire and by
keeping this age going we can keep the
dark souls games going but is that
really what we want many games have gone
on to make numerous sequels and ruin the
integrity of that series the age of dark
is not just about moving on from the age
of fire but from dark souls itself as
much as i want more dark souls games to
keep coming it's only going to ruin the
franchise going forward but that doesn't
mean we have to say goodbye to the souls
genre we have eldon ring and any other
souls games that come after it so our
hunger for this genre of games will
never die but we do need to say goodbye
to dark souls having dark souls end now
means it ends on a high note and i'd
rather see the game quit while it's
ahead then watch it release sequel after
sequel that will inevitably tarnish its
reputation causing it to be one of the
many games in the industry that ran
itself into the dirt so it's time to
finally put this game and its world to
rest
thank you for watching
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you made it this far then thank you
the length of this video was a lot
longer than i thought it would be but i
felt it was necessary if we're going to
talk about everything that dark souls 3
was trying to convey the dark souls
games to this day are still some of the
best games i've ever played as from
start to finish it managed to deliver
quality content that kept me engaged
across all three games and having dark
souls 3 be the end is fitting as a book
ends the series in a way i've never seen
done before we still have demon souls to
cover before we officially close the
curtains on the franchise though so look
out for that as for after that game well
i got a lot of plans but we could talk
about that next video as always thank
you to my returning viewers for coming
back to another video and take care
everyone
goodbye
you